the smallest legendarily land should be
all that catches a blanket of darkness
this to be bouncing servitude matones
oldest residence you have a member
mentions origins
you can have it history open dish it
survived
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's jump-scare
mansion formerly Spooky's House of jump
scare but now Spooky's jump-scare
mansion HD renovation the entire game
has been rebuilt in a brand new engine
in Full HD quality so I'm going to be
going into the mansion once again
because number one whoa you oh so nice
oh it looks so good
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna go and I'm gonna go in
these rooms and I'm gonna see all what
for but as you can obviously tell it's
different because number one it looks a
little better but obviously number two
there's a lot more diversity to what can
go on it here even though it's probably
gonna be a lot of this room wandered so
let's see what's in store in the
jump-scare mansion so i hello Brad how
are you doing
you're not very scary that's for damn
sure nice bad
bones I like the sounds they upped up
the sounds the creep factor is
definitely there oh hi oh hi bones are
you doing whoa hi bed oh hello beds All
Right see ya [ __ ] you you only gonna
scale me with those pathetic skews you
got to be scaring up a much spookier
sentence for what it's worth I'm gonna
go through the first like hundred or so
and just see see if there's some
spooktacular home waiting for me in the
darkness what are you goo p-- what are
you fog I don't know what you are but I
don't like it Oh rumble increases
GZA candy and i like it's got a baby
crib in a in a cave is that the timeout
chair looking at a wall don't like in
momomo is there another door over there
that's the question right why are there
so many a moveable that's a thing that
happened whoa hey buddy huh that gives
me the creeps
it's Redman beds whoa here we go whoa
that's so nice hang in there I will will
jail laughs its noise looks like there's
gonna be oh no another timeout chair I
don't know which way is the right way to
goes oh god I picked correctly come on
come on now come on
yeah ghost why is there another timeout
chair up there there are so many people
needing to be put into timeout I don't
like that I know what that is spouting
splashing soaking innards ingest
invoking nailing never stops a joke why
okay that's what that summoned I
shouldn't have read that out loud that's
not what I should have done oh that is
bad jump over it oh I can't jump you
know that'll teach me for reading random
bits of paper strewn about everywhere
yeah you never know when you're gonna
summon a demon okay seems like we got
away from it that's good you don't know
where I'm gonna come fool you if you do
that is it him it's gonna be up your
butt straight up your behold yeah where
am I going
Oh bony how you doing buddy oh you look
good
you've turned yourself into a Leveaux
ice cream or what are you cupcake ice
cream or a cupcake answer my goddamn
questions figures [ __ ] out man
leave it to me whoa okay but I was in a
box why did I hear breathing was it you
oh that's why oh hey this is going
friend like I thought I was done with
you
oh this we're you doing okay you got to
follow the rails don't 100 let's do a
hundred okay that was pretty good
keep a little pep in your step go down
Oh somebody will oil that door Oh Goldie
good beef line
get away tentacle ban and one of the
things actually gonna get spooky opinion
well I spoke me scare me honey please
somebody please wait whoa well found the
sewer oh it's awfully goopy in here it's
like a lot of this place is suspiciously
goopy you know I expect a normal level
of goo pitch in every place that I go to
so when it's above level average doo doo
I heard that I heard that I heard that
sorry about don't mean to complain about
the goog levels goop levels are
perfectly adequate oh well that fog in
my face is probably a bad sign
and remember what that is though well
that's locked okay well that's no good
hehe I think something's gonna leave me
when I die
oh well
a loop or a loop-de-loop maybe if I go
backwards yep oh no wait no oh god no no
oh
what's nice we're we're we're we're all
oh hey buddy
Oh Baby how you doing good okay well
this is Oh one's a scope a subject five
has growing more Restless I told the
spook we need more funds for sedatives
and she just laughed and flew into the
ceiling without more chemicals to keep
these things docile and not sure how
much longer we can safely keep them
generic lab assist what kind of person
would work in a lab in a mansion how did
they even get here I stand under that
yup that's a hole all right
I believe subject five is loose the
glass is shattered and I can faintly
hear clicking coming from the ceiling I
don't know what will happen now if it's
out in alive it'd probably be my last
report the clicking is getting louder Oh
Oh Lily
I don't like that I don't like that I
don't know what was going on but I don't
like it
well Shah I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dad dad I'm dad that's the
wrong way to go that's wrong hi I [ __ ]
it now okay well oh okay maybe I just
keep running then I guess I'm not done
here we go the clicking has stopped in
the giant holes in the ceiling or not
there anymore this is my last note I'm
gonna die I've never found my escape but
really that's not true this place was
like my escape when I escaped from
everything else in the end my deaths got
a romantic okay whatever you're dead not
cup of joe who ballroom there are nice
but apparently we're not what whoa whoa
that's not good pony run hey Bonnie
you made it Oh Bonnie Oh Bonnie you're
such a good corner keep that blood
pumping you got it buddy there Oh Oh big
and red you like big red lump in this
before
oh you goofy that's a new sound those
are new sounds I love new sounds
anything by me okay gosh [ __ ] I did bad
Oh God which way to go
locked oh they're locked it wouldn't
have mattered none anyway I can't read
it
miss sir he never came to class today I
hope she made it home okay Oh something
tells me it's re made it to class just
fine ah Oh could it really be true I
thought the fairy tales about the ghost
that eats children who sneak in after
class was just keep us from disobeying
but Matsuri is still missing
the ghost that eats children for a
project well that just means don't go to
class if you're late just don't go you
won't get eat you won't be at the
rumbling in my tumbly it seems to the
music seems very counter Wampus to
what's actually going on here ah back to
the choirs of the Damned my ideal
environment for thinking hey brainy
brainy you have a good one thinking and
such
whatever brains do masturbate probably
five nights at freddys whoa okay Wow fog
all right well then well bat me oh it's
all the time our chairs and bony thank
you here at the end oh that was lovely
all right so anyway that is Spooky's
House of jump-scares HD renovation
there's probably a lot of new stuff in
here but most of this I believe I've
seen over the years that I played this
game still really cool to see that
there's a full HD remake and I know it's
pretty nice feels a lot better to run
through it than it did before so check
it out for yourself it's on Steam and
thanks again for watching let me know
what you think down the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye